one of the things that happened during
our week off last week was that the
impeached president and people around
him continued to insist that impeachment
is no concern at all it's no big deal
everything's fine Trump impeached at
whatever doesn't really matter Trump's
not worried nobody's worried and yet
Donald Trump spent the better part of
the last week including nearly entire
day's rage tweeting about the fact that
he has been impeached on Christmas Day
evening so Christmas Day the 25th at
night and then the day after that Donald
Trump could not stop tweeting about
Democrats and impeachment and Nancy
Pelosi and even about home alone two if
you can believe it on Christmas Day
around 8:00 p.m. Eastern it began Trump
quote why should crazy Nancy Pelosi just
because she has a slight majority in the
house be allowed to impeach the
President of the United States got zero
Republican votes there was no crime the
call with Ukraine was perfect with no
pressure she said it must be bipartisan
and overwhelming but this scam
impeachment capitalizing scam and
impeachment we don't know why was
neither also very unfair with no capital
D due process proper representation or
witnesses now Pelosi is demanding
everything the Republicans weren't
allowed to have in the House Dems wanna
run majority Republican Senate
hypocrites so riddled with random
capitalization riddled with non
sequiturs following it up with a series
of tweets from very very early in the
morning all through later in the day
alluding once again to the upper Trump
we've talked about you've got downer
Trump or slowed-down Trump which is the
slurring Trump that often shows up at
rallies and speeches later in the day we
had video just in the last segment of
that version of Donald Trump from his
speech to Turning Point USA this Trump
which is the earlier in the day Trump
erratic hyped up seeming far more manic
continuing to tweet quote
the radical left do-nothing Democrats
said they wanted to rush everything
through to the Senate because quote
President Trump is a threat to national
security
they are vicious will say anything but
now they don't want to go fast anymore
they want to go very slowly liars
this is all so free of actual substance
that it doesn't really warrant specific
refuting beyond recognizing number one
this is an unwell person number two this
is a very scared person but again how
can Trump call them the do-nothing
Democrats if they went and impeached him
it seems they're doing things to the
extent that they can of course without
controlling the Senate they're just not
the things that Donald Trump likes this
is not the behavior of someone who isn't
worried about impeachment and of course
more than half the country supports him
being an impeached president which is
what he is this is the political
equivalent to your neighbor yelling get
off my lawn two little kids cutting
across the corner lot this is your wacky
uncle furious with a cloud at
Thanksgiving Nancy Pelosi has clearly
triggered this guy and we now are going
to have to bear the brunt of it for the
next how long right I mean possibly for
the next year possibly for the next five
years we could have five more years of
this up coming and by the way now that
we've had another ten days of time to
observe exactly as we predicted before
our vacation Nancy Pelosi holding the
impeachment articles from the Senate for
now has worked exactly as we believed it
would it has thrown Donald Trump into a
tantrum Inspiral petrol in child mode
that we have seen to the nth degree
Trump is impeached and yet he now has to
wait before the trial gets going and it
is driving him absolutely up a wall
dozens and dozens of tweets about Nancy
Pelosi he can't control himself and it
is turning out it's either by chance or
by plan I don't know it is one of the
most clever moves that Nancy Pelosi has
made she's done a lot of terrible
misguided things
I think that actually the entire
impeachment being focused only around
Ukraine was a mistake what about
emoluments what about Yemen there's so
many other things that are arguably even
stronger but this holding of the
articles of impeachment for the time
being has worked really well we could
expect Trump to continue tantruming all
throughout the New Year's holiday and
well into 2020
maybe this will even be the subject or
at least discussed during Donald Trump
State of the Union address early in 2020
although at the same time his advisors
may successfully convince him not to
talk about that we will see but this is
working really well and so far actually
a pretty good move by Nancy Pelosi
amidst many not-so-good moves so we will
continue covering this and from reaction
and Republican defenses including on
Instagram make sure you're following us
on instagram at david pakman show follow
me on Instagram while you were there at
David Pakman lots of videos and pictures
from my vacation last week some of which
have people quite titillated I will say
but I will say no more we'll take a
quick break and be back after this